voilà une autre qui nous ont fait marrer
on a le calendrier des chiens trop
mignon c'est simple c'est un mois une
crotte regard des calendriers des cards
ils ont essayé de motiver les pêcheurs
regardez c'est sûr que t'as plus envie
d'aller à la pêche là c'est sûr quel
calendrier fait un énorme carton ce
moment c'est en russie c'est celui de
vladimir poutine
et c'est pas une bonne chaque mois pour
retrouver bladimir poutine a un pelage
la dîmière poutine avec un chien bladi
mines pau verdier mire poutine qui
chevauche un ours
regardez on la voit là il va chevaucher
un amour voilà normal il est tranquille
quoi le débat mais voilà il se fait son
petit alors du coup nous ce matin j'ai
vu ça je me suis dit que peut-être on
pouvait faire le calendrier tpm paix
mais pas contre un petit business
donc on est allé dans la rue essayez de
vendre le calendrier
regardez si ce calendrier tpp
[Musique]
carey touche pas on passe jean-michel
awa alpes
ça c'est pas prêt à l'acheter non pas
parce que t'as qu'à l'hiver n'est pas un
beau corps jean michel mr a non non non
non je préfère qui mettra pour le vert
ce réseau fait ça abate super beau gosse
comme ça imaginons l'accrocha dans le
salon les employés ça ça pour quoi
j'adore ces poils et surtout le petit
ring combien vous êtes prêts à donner
pour ce calendrier 0
le maire gérald ça c'est sympa c'est
dégueulasse et on en a vendu un nom